just a little ways into my first few
years of college I was singing opera
Arias and by day and um and at night I
was singing uh songs in clubs you know
playing guitar and and singing and
writing my own songs and doing cover
tunes for everything from Joni Mitchell
to Talking Heads
and um
uh I became very interested in more
experimental music but what I was
Finding was that it was very hard when I
was using the same tools
guitar and voice basically to get out of
the habits that you fall into and change
the mode of what I was producing so I
ended up buying a digital delay
and
it was really that night I came home
from the music store hooked everything
up and started singing through it and
that was incredibly major turning point
very quickly like I'd say within a year
the guitar almost just completely
disappeared out of my arsenal of tools
and um I was mainly making pieces for my
voice and some found objects to use for
percussion like I was playing like a
pair of hammer handles I was playing a
slinky like the wonderful toy I was
playing uh you know anything I get my
hands on that was interesting visually
and at the same time could make a sound
and I was grabbing little bits of that
into the digital delay along with little
fragments of my voice I was starting to
use text in my work because I was
finding out that I could create music
from the melody that's found in speaking
text if you repeat that text by sampling
it that you very quickly discover the
musicality of it so it was a really huge
moment for me when I just started
playing with processing my voice